more than 500 rohingya refugees escaped
from a temporary detention center in
malaysia early on wednesday six were
killed while trying to cross a highway
after the escape in northern penang
state
police say more than half of those who
got out have been found and rearrested
let's get more now from lawrence
florence louis who is in kuala lumpur
for us so what prompted the breakout
well according to the police chief of
cada state now there was a riot that
preceded the breakout
more than 500 people escaped after they
broke down door and grill barriers
the detention center was holding around
600 people at the time and there were
around 23 security personnel now the
kada police chief did not give further
information about what could have
prompted the riot but he did concede
that there could have been feelings of
dissatisfaction among the detainees but
he didn't elaborate further now he did
say that an investigation a police
investigation has been launched this
temporary detention center is
between the border between the states of
penang and kada and that's why you've
got the police chief of these two states
making police making media statements
now we also know that six people
including two children were killed while
trying to cross a highway in the early
hours of wednesday morning we also know
that more than 150 detainees remain at
large police say they have set up
roadblocks to try and recapture the rest
also the volunteer paramilitary call has
also been activated to try and recapture
these people now according to the police
all those who escaped are rohingya
refugees meaning they are likely to have
escaped from myanmar where they're being
persecuted or from refugee camps in
bangladesh where there's just misery and
hardly any future to look forward to now
malaysia does not recognize refugees but
this country this muslim majority
country remains a very popular
destination for the mainly muslim
rohingya
even though they know that when they get
here they have no rights they are at
risk of arrest detention and deportation
even while they await for asylum in a
third country
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much florence